اهلا بكم مستمرون معكم في تغطنا للاوضاع
والتطورات المتلاحقه في السودان في اليوم
السادس من المواجهات المسلحه لا يزال
طرفها صراع يتبادلان الاتهامات بخرق هدنه
بدات هشه وفشلت كسابقتها في حقن دماء
واقفه اطلاق النار لليوم الثاني على
التوالي وفي وقت لا الصوت فيه يعلو على
اصوات الرصاص المتبادل هناك خوف كبيره من
تفاقم الازمه الصحيه
[موسيقى]
وفي مواجهه بين قائدي الجيش والدعم السريع
اعلاميا حمل عبد الفتاح البرهان قوات
الدعم السريعه التي يقودها محمد حمدان
ديجالو حميد هي المسؤوليه الكامله عن
اعمال النهب في الخرطوم ودارفور واكد في
تصريحات لصحيفه
جزءا كبيرا من قوات الدعم السريع خرجت عن
سيطره حميتي وقال ان الانتقال الى المسار
الديمقراطي مرهون بهزيمه قوه حميتي من جهه
وفي تصريحات ايضا اكد حميتي بان قواته لن
تتراجع عن اهدافها وتعهد بتقديم البرهان
للمحاكمه واوضح حميدت بانه منفتح على وقف
اعمال العنف لكنه اشار الى ان البرهان لن
يفعل الامر نفسه متهم نياهو بانه ليس
مستعدا للانتقال للحكم المدني حسب التعبير
[موسيقى]
هذا هو نشر الجيش السوداني مقطع فيديو
يظهر سيطرته على قاعده في شمال غرب البلاد
التي تعتبر من اكبر خطوط الامداد لقوات
الدعم السريع
ثم استلام معسكر الشفرليت التابع لقوات
الدعم السريع بعد ان اقام هاربين منها تم
استلام عدد خمسه عربه الاندروزر وعدد واحد
تمر وكميه من الاسلحه
حريق في مهند للسلاح مهند للسلاح حريق في
الخرطوم اثنين شارع الصناعات شارع
الصناعات في العمارات اللي قاعده فوق وما
قادر تطلع فلوس قاعده فوق ما قادره تطلع
حريق حريق
حريق
[تصفيق]
في اي جهه ممكن تيجي تتدخل في الحته دي
الناس مفروض تجي في الحته دي فوق
اطفال قاعدين فوق في العماره والناس ما
قدرت تطلع
وفي ثلاثه ولا اكثر من اربع عمارات موجوده
تحت لبعض وهادي الناس حسك على التجري
نداء استغاثه يا جماعه في اكتر من اربع
عمارات جنب بعض يفوز قاعده فوق ما قادر
تنزل في مقابلتها من قوات الدعم السريعه
الجيش السوداني بمهاجمتك قوتها في ام
درمان واشارت الى تمكن قوتها من التصدير
للهجوم على تمركزاتها في غرب المدينه
واضافت القوات ان عناصرها اسقطت مروحيتين
للقوات الجويه السودانيه واكدت على ما
وصفته بالتزام قواتها بالبقاء في مواقعها
واقفل اطلاق النار منذ اعلان الهدنه
حرب السلطه او الجنرلين دخلت يومها السادس
وفيما الاشتباكات تتواصل تتزايد المخاوف
من توسع رقعه النزاع ليدق اسوار الدول
المجاوره ويزعزع امنه
حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخرت لها طالما ان
الجنراللين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها شخص
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لحق بالركب ولم يفته القطار دوله
شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه والعسكريه
كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا ولبنان حيث
يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع بالسياده وحق
تقرير المصير اي دول ديجيري وفق القانون
الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على الجانب الاخر
من القائمه دول مسلوبه القرار ومهمشه بحكم
الواقع او دي فاكتور
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرلين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فبايض ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
من الخرطوم بحري ينضم الينا صحفي عمار
بوشيبا عمار مرحبا بك ما الذي يجري الان
في الخرطوم بحري
يعني الان نسمع عديد من الاصوات ربما
مدفعيه واصوات لطلقات الناريه في مدينه
بحري بالاتجاه
الشرقي منطقه
كافوري بشكل واضح ومسموع لكثير يعني من
الاصوات
وايضا نسمع اصوات الانفجارات داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم هذه الاصوات ربما عادت قبل دقائق
والان بعد ان توقفت ولا نشاهد لا تحليق
للطيران الحربي ولا ارد من الجانب الاخر
ولكن نسمع هذه الاصوات والكثافه يعني
ما مدى تاثر الخرطوم بحري الان بهذه
الاشتباكات على الصعيد الانساني
لم اسمعك خالد السؤال مره اخرى المدى مدى
تاثر الخرطوم بحري الان واحيائها بهذه
الاشتباكات انسانيه
في المدينه يعني المواطن اصبح يتحرك في
خطوط معينه واصبح يتكيف مع هذا الوضع
ويستطيع ان يقضي حاجيته او يذهب الى مناطق
معينه في اوقات معينه نستمع لهذه الاصوات
وهي في طرف اطراف المدينه داخل الاحياء
ربما لا توجد قوات متحصنه بشكل كبير وواضح
ربما في اطراف ومداخل هذه الاحياء عند
شارع الشهيد مطر وشارع المعونه وعند ايضا
جسر شمبات الذي يربط ما بين مدينه درمان
ومدينه بحري في هذه الاثناء ولكن داخل
الاحياء يتحرك المواطن بحذر شديد يعني
هنالك موجه عطش كبيره جدا داخل الاحياء
مدينه البحري بنسبه كبيره الاحياء التي
تضررت المواطنون الى استخدام الاعبار في
هذه المنطقه هنالك مركز للكلى في منطقه
الصافيه مركز غسيل الكلى توقف تماما
للقطاع المياه وتذبذب والكهرباء ايضا كذلك
في هذا المركز في عدد من المستشفيات هي في
مناطق الاشتباكات بالقرب من السوق الكبير
سوق البحري وهذه المستشفيات خرجت على
الخدمه بشكل كبير وواضح وعدم ولا يستطيع
المواطن ان يصل لهذه المنطقه لتواجد
القوات في هذه المنطقه
مو حجم انتشار عناصر قوات الدعم السريعه
الان في الخرطوم بحري عمار
القوات تتحصل باتجاهين يعني باتجاه منطقه
كافوري وباتجاه منطقه شارع المعونه ويوجد
امتداد لهذه القوات ايضا على الشارع
البلديه الذي يتاخم منطقه السوق الكبير
كانت هنالك اشتباكات بالطيران قبل يومين
مما ادى الى حرق السوق الكبير هذه
الاشتباكات ادت الى حق السوق الكبير بنسبه
كبيره تضرر هذا السوق وربما شاهدنا العديد
من الصور الوضع الميداني يدل على انه
هنالك ارتكازات وتحصينات جيده لهذه القوات
على ارض على ارض
المعركه ولكن يستخدم الطيران الحربي طلعت
جويه تحليق وربما للتصوير ترد لمضادات
الارض
يه موجوده
في الارض وتتحصن رغم الخناس اليوم السادس
هذه القوات ما زالت سلاح لديها موجود وما
زالت ترد على كثير من الطلاق الجويه كل
هذه القوات اي حواضن شعبيه في الخرطوم
بحري عمار النظر الى التركيبه يعني
لم اسمعك ان كان لدى هذه القوات او هذه
العناصر اي حواضر شعبيه في هذه المنطقه
الخرطوم بحري
ليست لديها حواضر شعبيه ولكن هي لا تحتك
بالمواطن يعني هنالك سمعنا عن حاله سلبو
لعدد من المواطنين يحتقوا بهذه القوات
وهذه القوات توجد ايضا في ارتكازات على
مستوى الشوارع هنالك مواطنون يلجاون
للمناطق الاخرى متوفره فيها المياه العذبه
يذهبون لجلب المياه
واحيانا يحتكون وتوجد هذه القوات في عدد
من المنافذ هنالك من قالوا بانهم تعرضوا
هنالك من قالوا بانهم لم يتعرضوا شيء وهذا
ربما دفع قوات الدعم السريع للاصدار بيان
ب
ان هناك يلبسون او يرتدون زي قوات الدعم
السريع ويحتكون بالمواطن بشكل كبير هذا
ربما دفع هذه القوات للتص ولكن العمليه
تمضي يعني هنالك من يشتكي وهنالك من لا
يشتكي شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم بحريه
الصحفي عمار بوشيب
ونذهب الى الخرطوم ايضا ونبقى فيها ربما
في وسط العاصمه ينضمين الكاتب الصحفي محمد
شمس الدين محمد مرحبا بك هل لك ان تشرح
لنا الان هذه الادخنه التي تتصاعد في سماء
العاصفه من اي منطقه
واين تتركز المواجهات وهل ما زالت قويه في
حجمها يعني مقارنه بالايام الماضيه خصوصا
في محيط القياده العامه والقصر الرئاسي
تحيه طيبه لك اخي خالد وليس هذا المشاهدين
اينما كانوا هذه الادخنه التي تتصاعد في
منطقه غرب المطار هي
المنطقه تماما بالمناسبه يعني الاصوات
ربما تابعتموها قبل قليل كانت غايه في
الحده نتيجه للقصف المكثف الذي كان متركزا
على هذه المنطقه والشوارع المحيطه بغرب
المطار وغرب مقر القياده العامه الاحياء
المجاوره لهذا الشريط احياء معروفه به
الخرطوم اثنين والخرطوم واحد والخرطوم
ثلاثه هو العمارات
ويعني وصولا حتى الصحافه هناك يعني جيوب
لهذه القوات تتنقل بسرعه وتتنقل بين
الاحياء يعني وهي تحمل بطبيعه الحال
المدافع الرشاشه
تحاول ان تبعد القوات الجويه من ان تقصفها
المباني قبل قليل كانت تهتز في اعنف موجه
يعني تبادل لاطلاق القذائف
مختلف احجامها بعض يعني المرفقات في هذه
المباني بدات في تساقط بطبيعه الحال
ويعني شاهدنا الكثير منها وهو يتساقط في
المبنى الذي نحن فيه هذه الموجه كما اسلفت
هي الاقوى اليوم
وتفسر يعني كل ما
يرد في بيانات القوات المسلحه
هذه القوات التي اشرنا اليها قبل قليل
اعدادها كبيره ويبدو انها
يعني تعزيزات قدمت لقوات الدعم السريع كما
من الطرف الاخر قدمت لقوات الجيش وشهدت
تلك التعزيزات في لقطات مختلفه ومتفرقه
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هذه الضربات
ايضا تمتد نحو
منطقه
كفوري وكذلك شرق النيل هذه هي المناطق
التي تتحرك فيها هذه القوات ايضا يعني
سرعه يعني تحاول الاختباء ما بين المدنيين
طريقه الاختباء ايضا هذه بالمناسبه مرئيه
لكثيرين الاهالي في الاحيان لا يستطيعون
الان التنقل والخروج يعني على الرغم من ان
هناك هدنه معلنه لكن بطبيعه الحال هي هذه
المره فاشله بجميع المقاييس لماذا لان هذه
المجموعات باتت يعني حتى تغلق مداخل
الابواب العمارات المباني يعني التي هي
يعني يقطنها ساكنها وتبحث عن اقرب شجره
يعني تجلس تحتها وما الى ذلك هذه هي
الطريقه يعني ستعتبر المدنيين دروعا بشريه
بشكل مباشر ستمنع اي نوع من انواع القذف
في حساباتهم وهذا ايضا
يتسبب في يعني ازعاج هؤلاء
المواطنين في هذه المناطق حين اطلاق
القذائف الرشاش او من المدفعيه الرشاشه
الاصوات مزعجه جدا لدرجه تصم الاذان يعني
نحن حتى الان هذه الاصوات سببت لنا يعني
نوع من التحسس في الاذان مازلنا نسمع تردد
هذه الاصوات او يعني لا اعرف ما الذي حصل
على وجه الدقه ربما نحتاج الى طبيب بعد
انتهاء هذه العمليات وتشوف شر التعزيزات
التي تصل الى قوات الدعم السريع في اليوم
السادس من اين تاتي ما هو مصدرها
بطبيعه الحال هي تاتي من خارج الخرطوم
كانت هناك انباء عن يعني تحركات لبعض
القوات قادمه من معسكرات في غرب البلاد
يعني ايضا
قوات قادمه لتعزيز القادم للقوات الجيش من
معسكراتها ايضا في القضارف في شرق البلاد
هذه المره هذه يعني كلها تنبا باحتدام
المعركه
بطبيعه الحال صعوبه وصول الطواقم الصحفيه
الى بعض مواقع الاشتباكات او حتى يعني
نقل الصوره من زوايا مختلفه يصعب على
الصحفيين الحصول على المعلومه بشكل ادق
حتى يعرف
المشاهد من اين تاتي هذه القوات يعني اين
كانت قبل ان تكون في الخرطوم كل هذه
المعلومات لابد من التواجد الميداني حتى
يتمكن الصحفي من جمعها لكننا نحاول ان
نجمع كل ما نستطيع عبر ما يتوفر على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
نقوم بمحاوله التواصل مع المصادر المختلفه
في لدى مختلف القطاعات
المتواجده في هذه
يعني في مسرح العمليات نتمكن من الوصول
اليهم لكن في معظم الاوقات لا نستطيع
التواصل ومعظم الهواتف تكون مغلقه يعني
محاوله تثبت من بعض الاخبار وبعض
التسريبات التي تخرج بين الفين والاخرى كل
هذه الانباء والمعلومات يعني ايضا نحاول
الترجيحها عبر بعض الخبراء العسكريين
نحاول يعني التحقق منها بشكل او باخر
ونحصل على معلومات قريبه من الواقع هذا
فيما يتعلق بمحاوله معرفه يعني تفاصيل بعض
هذه التعزيزات والقوات نوعيه التعزيزات
هذه ايضا ربما ملحوظه هذه المره هناك
عربات مثبته عليها
قاذفات جديده ربما تشاهد لاول مره انا لا
اعرف مسماها ولكنها يعني ملحوظه بشكل
مختلف بنفس طريقه تثبيت
المدافع الرشاشه الدوشكا هي مثبته ولكنها
يعني كبيره جدا في الحجم اشبه بقاذفات
الهاون هذه ما لوحظت هناك ايضا ملاحظه
عليها وهي تواجد سيارات الصليب الاحمر
للمره الاولى ربما بعد الكثير من النداءات
شوهدت وهي تجوب بعض احياء الخرطوم شوهد
ايضا قبل قليل عددا من العائلات ويعني
تخرج من منازلها يعني على الرغم من نوعوره
المنطقه او صعوبه الخروج من هذه المنطقه
المكتظه
عناصر دعم سريعه الذين يقومون بايقاف
الجميع ومحاوله يعني معرفه الى من ينتمون
وما الى ذلك ومحاوله يعني الحصول منهم على
ما يصدر رمقهم شاهدنا بعض هذه العناصر
ايضا قبل قليل وهي يعني ربما تحاول الحصول
على المواد الغذائيه من بعض وهذا امر
متفهم هذا امر يعني انساني يستغربه
السودانيون ايضا في احاديث السودانيين
فيما بينهم يقولون يعني لما يعني وصلنا
الى هذا الحال هؤلاء يحتاجون الى المياه
والى الطعام وبامكاننا تقديم المساعده لهم
لكنهم يتخوفون من يعني يحصل لهم ما حصل
لكثير من العائلات بالامس وقبل امس وهم
يحاولون مغادره
الخرطوم او حتى وهم يعني يقومون
بمنع هذه المجموعات التي تحاول اقتحام
المنازل للحصول على ما بداخلها
مدى قوه محمد هذه الاشتباكات التي تجري
الان يعني خاص خصوصا في محيط ربما لنبدا
بمحيط
القصر الجمهوري جنوب مطار الخرطوم حيث
تحدث الان هذه الاشتباكات وسمعنا قبل قليل
قصفا قويا يعني مقارنه بالايام الخمسه
السابق هل هي بالذات الوتيره بذات القوه
اقل اقوى هل يمكن الحديث عن انحسار لهذه
الاشتباكات في مناطق معينه الاقرب من
المطار اقرب من القاعده العامه الى مناطق
بدات يعني تاخذ حيزا ابعد منها
تقريبا خالد هي في ذات المواقع منذ بدء
العمليات ربما اليوم كان هناك موقعا جديدا
شوهدت اعمده الدخان وهي تتصاعد من منطقه
وسط الخرطوم او السوق العربي كما يعرف
السودانيون هذه المنطقه وهي منطقه تقع
جنوب القصر الجمهوري هذه المنطقه تحركت
فيها عربات الدعم السريع بكثافه عاليه
وتنقلت يعني من هذه المنطقه الى الاحياء
التي تقع جنوب هذه المنطقه جميعها هناك من
المواطنين من يعني
يعطي هذه المعلومات على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
ويحذر المواطنين من التفاعل معهم باي صوره
من الصور نسبه لما حدث في الايام الماضيه
بالنسبه لحده هذه المواجهات ونوعيه
استخدام المقذوفات ايضا فيها تغير ملحوظ
جدا هذه المره هذا اليوم تحديدا يعني
الحد ربما استطيع تقييمها بثلاثه اضعاف
اكثر
قبل الامس بكل اسف شديد يعني هذه كما
اسلفت يعني تصم الاذان هناك شكاوى كثيره
من العائلات المتواجده والتي لديها اطفال
في هذه المناطق يشتكون من ان الوضع النفسي
متدهور جدا جدا جدا للاطفال
هذه الاصوات هذه الاصوات تكون اما عبر
اطلاق المقذوفات في اتجاه
الطيران او في اتجاه مواقع داخل ربما
القياده من هذه المناطق او نتيجه سقوط بعض
القذائف في المنطقه هذه القذائف قويه جدا
لا احد يعرف ايضا حجم تاثير هذه القذائف
لماذا لانه لا توجد صور حتى هذه اللحظه
نقيم من خلالها هذه المقذوفات نحاول يعني
ان نقدر المسافه ايضا لا نستطيع فقط نستمع
الى اصوات قويه جدا واهتزازات قويه جدا
هذه الاصوات ايضا احيانا تكون بدون سابق
انذار احيانا نستطيع تمييز او معرفه ان
صوتا قويا سيقع ان سمعنا صوت الطيران
الحربي او صوت المسيرات التي تسبق ايضا
هذا الصوت القوي ولكن لا اعرف يعني لماذا
لا توجد اي طريقه اخرى لتنبيه الناس قبل
يعني استخدام هذا النوع من انواع الاسلحه
وتضمينيهم ايضا عن يعني
تبعات هذا الامر ومدى محدوديه هذا السلاح
في يعني اصابته لاهداف بعينها دون الاضرار
باهداف او
بممتلكات اخرى سيارات في الشارع نوافذ
للبيوت او ما الى ذلك لا توجد اي معلومات
ايضا او ارشادات للناس لكيفيه حمايه
النوافذ من يعني الشظايا التي من المحتمل
ان تدخل الى بيوتهم وقد شوهد الكثير او
شوهدت اللقطات كثيره على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي للنوافذ وهي اخترقت او تهشمت
وجراء هذه القذائف او الشظائف التي تنطلق
من هذه القذائف كلها امور لابد من التركيز
عليها الغرفه غرفه العمليات التي تم عنها
ايضا هناك تساؤلات كثيره لماذا ليس هناك
من تفاعل حقيقي من غرفه العمليات الخاصه
بالدفاع المدني التي تم الاعلان عنه
بالامس ما زالت شكاوي المواطنين حول مساله
المياه يعني متكرره يعني الناس شبه يعني
فقدوا الامل فيما يتعلق بتلقي المعونه من
جهات معنيه مسؤوله يفترض ان تجد لهم حلا
لا احد يطمئن الناس فيما يتعلق بمساله
المياه المناطق التي وصلتها المياه من من
عدمها هناك بعض المناطق قام الاهالي
بمحاوله اصلاح الشبكات
يعني بطريقه تطوعيه ولكن هناك مناطق اخرى
لم تصلها هذه المياه شبكه الكهرباء ايضا
هناك معاناه في عمليه توفير الكهرباء عبر
طريقه الشراء المعتاده وهنا تبرز ال ال
الحوجه الماسه لان تكون هناك فتره من
فترات
المواقف الوطنيه بان تفتح هذه الشركات
الخدمات التي تعطى يعني مقابل بدون هذا
المقابل لا يمكن الحصول على الخدمه من هذه
الخدمات الخدمات الاتصالات المختلفه
وخدمات الكهرباء هذه من الخدمات الرئيسيه
التي لا يمكن للمواطن اليوم ان يعيش
بدونها فهناك متكرره لشركات الاتصالات
المختلفه لان تقوم ربما بفتح خدمات
الانترنت والاتصالات للناس لانها وسائل
تواصل ضروريه وحيويه لان يطمئن الناس على
بعضهم لان يعني تحصل يعني يحصل الجميع على
المعلومه في غياب هذه المعلومه من قبل
وسائل الاعلام التقليديه التي ربما هي غير
قادره على تقديم الخدمه لذات الاسباب
المعركه ربما هناك من يقول ربما
من الصعب ان ان تحصل تغطيه اعلاميه محايده
في هذه الظروف نسبه لحده او خطوره الموقف
الامني على الارض وهذا قد يتفهم الى درجه
ما ولكنه قد يعني يحل
عبر يعني فتح خدمه الانترنت للناس ليتبادل
الناس المعلومات فيما يتعلق بتطورات
الموقف اولا باول محمد شمس الدين اذهب الى
نزار بقداوي مراسل العربيه من مدينه مروي
نزار هل من جديد
الجديد باننا الان داخل هذا المطار وداخل
القاعده العسكريه العملياتيه في مدينه
مروي هذا هو برج المراقبه الرئيس للقاعده
وللمطار هذا البرج الذي كنا يوم امس في
هذه النقطه وقد عاكسنا حجم الضرر الذي لحق
به الان سنحاول ان نقترب اكثر عبر هذا
البث الحصري لقناه العربيه لمعرفه تفاصيل
ما حدث وحجم الضرر الذي لحق بهذا الجزء من
المطار وبالقاعده العسكريه العملياتيه
هذا الامر الان كما نتابع الان حجم للضرر
في هذه القاعده نحن الان سنقترب اكثر
نحن الان نصعد الى الدرجات العليا لهذا
البرج
وهو برج المراقبه الرئيس لهذا المطار الذي
يمتد لي عدد من الطوابق
كثير من الاضرار لحقت بهذا البرج الذي
يعول عليه كثيرا في العمليات الملاحيه
الجويه
هذا البرج خالد خلال الايام الماضيه كان
تحت محطه النيران نتيجه للاشتباكات التي
كانت متواصله في هذا الجزء
وفي هذه المنطقه
من القاعده العسكريه كل الصور الان التي
تشاهدها هي من داخل هذا البرج
نحن الان في مناطق عليا
من هذا البرج
الذي تضرر بحسب نفادات خاصه
لمدير المطار والان نشاهد
هذه هي بعض الطلقات
الناريه او الطلقات
الاسلحه هذا الضرر لهذا البرج
تشاهد الان
ايضا حجم الضرر في هذه المناطق
وصل اليها هذا البرج
مضرر كثير لحقت بالاجهزه هذه بعض الاجهزه
الفنيه التي تستخدم هنا في اطار العمليات
الملاحيه الجويه
ايضا تاثرت
نحاول ايضا ان نضعت اكثر
لمعرفه التفاصيل
واستجلاء المعلومه عن حجم الضرر عبر الصوت
والصوره وعبر البث الحي
ما زلنا داخل برج
المراقبه هذه اجهزه فنيه
اخبرونا انها
على درجه عاليه من الحساسيه
اجهزه تقنيه
ايضا تاثرت وتضررت
كما تشاهدون الان في هذه الصور
الخاصه لقناه العربيه
نمضي الان الى اعلى
الى المقر الرئيسي للبرج
هنا تدار كل العمليات الفنيه
والعمليات الاستراتيجيه لعمليه الملاحه
الجويه
هذه الاجهزه
اكيزه التواصل والاتصال
يبدو انها مدمره بالكامل
واستقبال الطائرات
عبر اجهزه الرادار محمد بالنسبه
هنا هذه الصور لهذه الاجهزه اللاسلكيه
يبدو انها خارج الخدمه مع من الان
كالنتيجه اشتباكات حصلت في هذه المواقع ام
تدمير للعناصر للدعم السريع ربما التي
كانت موجوده قبل انسحابها ماذا يقول
هو مؤكد خالد
المطروحه الان بان الاشتباكات كانت عنيفه
كل ما يحدث من ضرر هو نتيجه لهذا
الاشتباكات نتيجه للقصف العنيف الذي شهدته
هذه المنطقه
هذا ما يمكن ان نؤكد عليه بان الضرر وقع
نتيجه لعمل عسكري كانت هذه المنطقه من
المطار
مسرحا
وكانت ارضيه لكل العمليات العسكريه القصف
المدفعي القصف العنيف
حجم الضرر هذا الدمار الذي لحق بالمطار
لحق بالقاعده
لحقه بهذا البرج لهذه القاعده وهذا المطار
الذي يمثل احد اهم المطارات في المنطقه
الاقليميه لانه يطل على الاتجاه الشمالي
للسودان على حدود السودان مع دوله مصر
منهم مباشره يمكن ان يتم التنسيق كما فعل
مسبقا الجيش السوداني مع عدد من جيوش
الدول في المنطقه الاقليميه
ايضا يعتبر هذا المطار بديلا لمطار
الخرطوم الدولي اذا ما حدثت اي متغيرات في
مطار الخرطوم يتم الاستعانه بهذا المطار
عليه فان برج المراقبه يمثل اولويه في ان
يستعاد
عبر التوفير كل ما من شانه ان يسمح لهذا
البرج ان يعاود عمله وان تستكمل الاجهزه
التي
دمرت خلال الاشتباكات الاخيره
المراقبه والاليات التي تعاون هذا المطار
على العمل ولكن الحساسه اجهزه المراقبه
الجويه هي من تاثر المرافق الحيويه تاثرت
تدرك تماما بان مثل هذه المواقع
الاستراتيجيه الاجهزه المتعلقه بالاتصالات
وبالمراقبه وبتبادل المعلومات هي من
الحساسيه ومن الاهميه بمكان اي ضرر يقع
على هذه الاجهزه وهذه المعدات وهذه
الاليات الفنيه سيعقد صعوبه ان يعود
المطار ليعمل بكفاءته لكن
مختصون ايضا واداره هذا المطار ذكرت لنا
يوم الامس بانهم يعملون الان على حجم او
على حصر الاضرار وعلى رفع تقييم اول يدفع
به مباشره الى الجهات المختصه في الخرطوم
لمعرفه المدى الزمني والامكانيات الماديه
المتطلب توفرها حتى يعود هذا المطار الى
عمله كما كان سابقا
علينا ان نتحرك من من البرج المراقبه الى
مناطق اخرى ايضا اذا كان بامكانك ذلك نزار
لنتعرف اكثر على حجم الدمار الذي حل
باقسام في
المطار وهلنا نتعرف يعني على مدى اهميه
هذا المطار يعني حجم الضرر الواقع على
الناس التي كانت تستفيد من هذا المطار بعد
تعطله الان
يعني قد لا اجد زمن للتجوال في كل اجزاء
المطار ولكن هذه هي
الظرفيه الوقتيه التي سمحت لنا بان نكون
في هذا الجزء المعلومات المتوفره الان عن
حجم الضرر في هذا المطار هي معلومات تؤكد
ان الضرر كان ضررا جزئيا في كثير من
المحاور وفي كثير من المرافق وكان ضررا
كليا في عدد من المواقع المتعلقه
بالخدمات الملاحيه كما ذكرنا على سبيل
المثال برج المراقبه الذي تاثرت تاثرا
مباشرا بهذه العمليات والاشتباكات ايضا
خالد رصدنا يوم الامس ورصدنا اليوم بان
هنالك ضرر ايضا لحق به السيارات المعينه
لمطار مروي الدولي وهي سيارات الدفاع
المدني هذه السيارات تاثرت ايضا بشكل كلي
في بعض النواحي وبشكل جزئي
الكنترول او اداره السيارات الدفاع المدني
ايضا تاثرت هنالك بعض الصهاريج الوقود
تاثرت ايضا
بالاشتباكات هذه الصهااريت كانت تقع في
الجهه التي كانت توجد بها قوات الدعم
السريع ايضا
علمنا بان الاسعافات اللي كانت التي كانت
موجوده في مطار مروي الدولي هي الان اختفت
ليست موجوده هذا ايضا يشير الى حجم الضرر
الذي لحق بهذا المطار ولحق بهذا المرفق
الاستراتيجي
الذي وجد نفسه جزءا من عمليه عسكريه بدات
في هذا المطار ثم امتدت لتشمل عدد من
المناحي وعدد من المدن في السودان لكن
الان الذي يقال حول هذا الضرر وحول ما حدث
في مطار مروي الدولي بانه نتيجه لما حدث
خلال الايام الماضيه الوضع بعمومياته كان
ملتبسا وكان معقدا القصف الجوي حتى
المواطنون لم يستطيعوا ان يستبينوا الموقف
ويتعرف على وضعيه ابنائهم في هذه القاعده
وفي هذا المطار الا بعد مرور ايام عديده
حتى انجلى الامر وحتى بسطت القوات المسلحه
السودانيه سيطرتها على عموم المطار
واستطاعت اتيام وفرق السلاح المهندسين ان
تبدا في عمليه حصر الاضرار والتعامل مع
الاجسام الغير منفجره للذخائر والدانات
التي تم استخدامها بكثافه هنا داخل هذا
المطار شكرا جزيلا لك من مطار مروي مراسل
العربيه نزار
رصدنا الاوضاع في مروي لك لماذا اتجهت
الانظار الى هذه المدينه على مدار الايام
الماضيه كانت الفتيل الذي اندلعت منه
شراره الاولى للمواجهه الراهنه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم
محاور عده للنزاع في السودان من ابرزها ما
يدور في العاصمه لكن الاعين تتوجه ايضا
لمنطقه اخرى الى اكبر ولايات السودان
الولايه الشماليه التي برز من بين مدنها
بشكل لافت مروي الواقعه على بعد 350
كيلومترا شمال العاصمه الخرطوم المدينه
ذات اهميه عسكريه كبيره ازدادت مع الصراع
الحالي بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع جل
التركيز صب على مطار المدينه للجانبين
المدني والعسكري وتضاربت الانباء حول
الجانب المسيطر عليه الى ان اعلن الجيش عن
اعاده السيطره على مطار مروي المطار يعتبر
قاعده جويه مسانده ومنطقه تمركز بديله
للقواعد العسكريه الاخرى في السودان ويغطي
مطارها العمليات الجويه في شمال السودان
وشرقه وغربه اهميه مطار مروي تتاتى من
كونه احد اكبر المطارات في افريقيا فهو
يقع على مساحه 18 كم وهو مصمم لاستيعاب
هبوط واقلاع الطائرات الضخمه بمهبط طائرات
بطول حوالي اربعه كيلو مترات وعرض 60 مترا
وفي مطار مروي ومحيطه تنتشر قوات الفرقه
تسعه عشر التابعه للجيش السوداني المسؤوله
عن حمايه المرافق الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
انا في استوديوهاتنا ايضا مديره مكتب
العربيه في الخرطوم يعقوب اهلا لينا اذا
كان هناك لديك ولن معلومات اضافيه حول
مطار مروي الصوره التي جاءتنا قبل قليل من
خلال زميلنا نزار بقداوي
قاعده مروه هي قاعده عسكريه جويه تم
انشاؤها يعني بعد افتتاح سد مروي في العام
2010 هي تقع على بعد اربعه كيلو مترات من
مدينه مروي الشماليه تشرف ايضا على الطريق
الرابط بين المدينه وجسم سد مروي
واعتمدت هذه القاعده كبديله لقاعده وادي
سيدنا وهذه القاعده معروفه انها كانت حدثت
فيها عمليه الذراع الطويل وهو هجوم سابق
لحركه العدل والمساواه كان في عام 2008
تبلغ مساحه هذه القاعده 18 كيلو متر مربع
كذلك طول المدرج 4 كيلومترات عرضه نحو 60
متر هي تبعد عن الخرطوم
350 كيلومترا
بالحسابات العسكريه ولكن مثلا نحن في
الخرطوم او حتى في الانترنت مكتوب انها
تبعد نحو 500
كيلو متر تتواجد فيها دائما طائرات القوات
الجويه السودانيه باشكالها المختلفه من
طراز ميك 29 و26
وهي طائرات روسيه الصرع معروف طبعا ان
الحكومه السودانيه يعني في نظام البشير
كانت تتعامل مع روسيا في موضوع القاعدات
المعدات العسكريه فبالتالي هذه الطائرات
كلها روسيه الصنع اعيد تاهيل هذه القاعده
على يد المنظومات الدفاعيه لتستوعب طائرات
امريكيه حديثه ايضا جرت بالقاعده عده
مناورات في السنوات الماضيه ابرز هذه
المناورات كانت مع القوات الجويه المصريه
نسور النيل الواحد ونشور النيل اثنين
وكذلك احتضنت مناوره الرد على الازرق مع
القوات الجويه السعوديه في عام 2017 ممتاز
اليوم ونحن ننظر من خلال مشاهدات من كان
معنا يعني محمد شمس الدين قبل قليل اعطانا
ربما شرح مفصل لرقعه المواجهات ربما عكس
التوقعات لنا بان الرقعه هذه المواجهات
والاشتباكات بدات تتسع شيئا فشيئا دخول
مناطق جديده في وسط الخرطوم ربما على خط
هذه المواجهات ارسال تعزيزات عسكريه
للدعم السريع ايضا وصلت ربما الى هذه
المناطق
كذلك زياده وتيره القصف ايضا استخدام
اسلحه ربما الثقل خلال يعني
وتيره هذه
المواجهات اصبحت اقوى اليوم يعني كان من
المتوقع ان تخف الوتيره ربما
خاصه في المناطق التي تتركز فيها هذه
الاشتباكات
فلدي يعني بانه قوات الدعم السريع لديها
انتشار اصلا موجود في الكثير من المناطق
قبل انطلاق الرصاصه الاولى في هذه الحرب
قبل خمسه وسته ايام وبدات تتحرك الان
وتستخدم ادواتها وقواتها ام
ان هناك قدره لها في ايصال هذا الدعم من
مناطق اخرى سواء كان في العاصمه او من
خارج العاصمه كما حصل من بحري على سبيل
المثال والمعارك التي تمت فيها في اكثر من
مكان
صحيح خالتها اعتقد هذا سؤال مهم جدا وهو
سؤال يعني كان مسار لنقاش في السودان
لماذا لان قوات الدعم السريع
ومعسكرات الدعم السريع تتواجد في اطراف
العاصمه لذلك بامكانها الدخول الى العاصمه
بكل سهوله هذه المواقع كانت في السابق
تتبع لجهاز المخابرات وتتبع لهيئه
العمليات هيئه العمليات تم حلها بعد ثوره
ديسمبر حينما تم حلها تم توزيع كثير من
القوات التي كانت تتبع له هيئه العمليات
وتم حل كثير من القوات وهم كانوا بالالاف
الدعم السريع جاء والتمركز في هذه المواقع
ولم يكن اختيار هذا المواقع بصوره عبثيه
على الاطلاق فهي نعم مخطط هي ليست داخل
العاصمه ليس بامكانك ان تراهم ولكنها
موجوده في الاطراف في زوايا ومواقع مختلفه
تسهل لها تحديدا اذا ما اردنا استخدام او
سمينا هذه المناطق في الاطراف التي تتمركز
ربما فيها هذه
القوات بعد ان وصلت اليها يعني لكنك من
قواعد معينه
نعم هي توجد فيها يعني بحسب ما اعلم ربما
الان لا استحضر يعني كل الاسماء ولكن هناك
هناك هي موجوده
في الاطراف تتواجد فيها هذه القوات او
عناصر الدعم السريعه بشكل مكثف وتنتشر
يعني دعنا نتحدث مثلا عن الصالحه في طيبه
هناك ايضا حديث في كرري هناك منطقه جري
هذه ابرز الاماكن او المواقع لهيئه
العمليات هناك ايضا موقعين اخرين في
الحقيقه لا اذكر الاسماء ولكن هذه هي
مواقع لهيئه العفو لقوات الدعم السريع
والتي تمركزت بدل مواقع هيئه العمل
خالد لهذا ما يفسر اليوم قدرتها على ارسال
امدادات عسكريه داخل العاصمه داخل وسط
العاصمه من هذه المناطق ربما بالضبط هذا
هو لذلك
يوم شهود عيان من منطقه بحري يتحدثون انهم
يرون دبابات الدعم السريع في المنطقه لا
يرون الدبابات الجيش السوداني الجيش منتشر
بصوره اكثر في الخرطوم منتشر بصوره اكثر
ولكن نسبه لان هذه المعسكرات ربما لم يعني
تضرب بشكل تام او لم يتم الانتهاء منها
بشكل كامل تام ما زالت هناك قوات بامكانها
ان تنتشر في المدينه في فيديو رايناه امس
ايضا بثه عناصر من الجيش السوداني
لمعسكر في جبلوليا
نعم هذا المعسكر اشار الى سقوط مئات
القتلى من جانب الدعم السريع حتى اللحظه
وهو فيديو في الحقيقه كان صادم للغايه
يعني القتلى مرميين في بقرب المعسكر وهم
قرب بعضهم البعض
يشير لك هذا الى ان الاستهداف يتم الى
مواقع يعلم الجيش السود ان قوات الدعم
السريع تتمركز فيها على الجانب الاخر ايضا
الدعم السريع حينما يقوم باستهداف ايضا
مواقع هو يعتقد ايضا ان الجيش السوداني
يتواجد فيها لذلك يبادر القصف الى تلك
المناطق اليوم لم يحدث بحسب المعلومات
التي تحصلنا عليها اشتباك في محيط القياده
العامه الاشتباك كان قرب القصر الجمهوري
في منطقه بحري وكذلك في ام درمان
قليل الرب محمد
خلال فتره التي كنا نجري المقابله
الهاتفيه معه عندما نتحدث عن الصالحه وعن
كراري وعن جري هذه المناطق التي تتمركز
وتنتشر فيها قوات الدعم السريع وهي
مراكز يعني موجوده فيها من وقت سابق
هل يعني ان هذه المناطق تتحكم وتسيطر
بالفعل على هذه الاحياء الموجوده فيه
وبالتالي حركتها ستكون اسهل في الداخل
وعندما تنتقل الى وسط العاصمه هل هل
بالضروره ان نفسر الامر على هذا
داخل تمر عب هذه الجسور لا تسيطر عليها
يسيطر عليها الدعم السريع يعني الجيش
السوداني اقرب للجيش انا سيطره الجيش نعم
تحت سيطره الجيش المطار حتى وقت قريب كان
محل ايضا مثل قاعده مروي فيه اشتباك اي
انه ليس تحت سيطره الجيش بصوره تامه ولم
يكن تحت سيطره الدعم السريع رغم ان بيانات
كلا الطرفين تشير الى ان المطر تحت
سيطرتهما لكن بصوره ربما الان يعني اقرب
بحسب المعلومات المتاحه ان الجيش السوداني
هو الذي يسيطر على مطار الخرطوم ولكن
المطار اصبح شبه مدمر
ما هو الحال كما هو الحال بالضبط فيماوي
بحرهم بحر كذلك هناك مواجهات محتدمه الان
على اكثر من جبهه فيها ومعلومات عن
نزوح كبيره ايضا من اهالي هذه المنطقه
واحياء اخرى ايضا في العاصمه الخرطوم
اليوم كنت تستمع لشرح احد المراسلين يقول
بان هناك موقف اصبح مليء بالناس
وبالنازحين الذين يريدون الخروج من بعض
احياء الخرطوم تحديدا من بحري وصولا الى
ولايه البحر الاحمر او غيرها من المناطق
فهل من معلومات حول موجات النزوح الان نعم
خالد هذا السؤال مهم والان هذا الموضوع
يشغل بال كثير من السودانيين وتنشط بعض
الصفحات هناك اسر او مباني هي تحت القصف
لذلك اصبح مساله الانتقال من الخرطوم الى
احدى الولايات السودانيه هو انسب طريق
اذا كنت في الخرطوم فاسهل ان تذهب
وسط اعتقد ان الوضع صعب بالنسبه لتحركات
نعم يعني ان اردت السفر فهناك موقف مثل
كانه مثل المطار لكن هو طبعا ليس مطر هو
موقف للباص السفريه لم يستهدف هذا هذا
المكان بعد فان كانت هناك شجاعه لدى اصحاب
الباصات السفريه فهم من هناك يسافرون الى
ولايه سودانيه هؤلاء بالنسبه الى كل سكان
الخرطوم ان اردت او ان كنت في
الموقف هذا في الوسط في الشرق في الغرب
يعني نفكر نقرا في كيفيه تحرك الناس اقرب
للشرق بالنسبه
للاندرمان السوق الشعبي ايضا هناك باصات
في سوق الشعبي تنتقل الى ولايه سودانيه
طبعا يعني في كل منطقه بامكانها هذا
الموقف ان يذهب الى ولايات محدده يعني
طبعا انت تعرف ان السودان فيه مقاطعات
يعني كثيره اكثر الموجات هي تتجه الى
الولايات اللي على البحر البحر
المحمولايات البحر
يتجهون الى نهر النيل الى منطقه واد مدني
ايضا يعني هذه هي المناطق الاسهل
والاشتباكات حتى لنا هذه المناطق او اسمع
باشتباكات في نهر النيل او في الجزيره
معظم الاشتباكات كانت فقط في ربما اليوم
الاول القليل في بورسودان وكسله انتقلت
بعد ذلك الى ولايات دارفور
طبعا في الخرطوم الاشتباكات اكثر شيء ولكن
هناك ولايات لم يصلها حتى الان اي اشتباك
لان تواجد الدعم السريع يعني مثلا نهر
النيل لا يوجد في فيه تواجد للدعم السريع
لذلك هذه الولايه لم تشهد اي اشتباكات بين
جانبين حركه النزوح نقول كثيفه المقارنه
بالايام الماضيه بدات الناس تفكر جديا في
طريقه للخروج باي وسيله كانت من العاصمه
الخرطوم من المكان الذي تتركز فيه
الاشتباكات من كل الاحيان ومتوقع ان
تتصاعد هذه الحركه بعد احتدام المواجهات
خلال الايام ايضا القادمه سريعا لنا نعم
صحيح خالد لا اعلم ان كانت كلمه نزوح هي
الاصح عاده هؤلاء الاسس تذهب الى اقاربها
وهما الان قرروا يعني الان البيت السوداني
يستحمل رغم ضيقه يستحمل اكثر من ثلاث اسر
لان هناك اسر تعيش تحت قصف او تحت تهديد
لذلك اصبحت مساله السفر الى ولايه سودانيه
هي الخيار الانسب بالنسبه لهم خاصه مع شحن
المياه الغذا القدره على التحرك ايضا صحيح
حتى الاماكن التي عاد في عاد فيها
الكهرباء خالد هناك مشكله اخرى تواجه يعني
نحن ننتقل من مشكله الى مشكله اخرى عاد
التيار الكهربائي لكن تعطلت تطبيق بنكك
وتطبيق بنكك هو تطبيق مشهور في السودان
بامكان جميع المواطنين ان يدخلوا وان
يقوموا باعاده مثلا شحن الرصيد شحن
الكهرباء الدفع فواتير المياه هذا التطبيق
الان تعطل فما هو الطريقه الاخرى الطريقه
الاخرى ان تذهب الى مقر هيئه الكهرباء
وتدفع وتشتري وهذه المقام مغلقه
حتى ان عاد التيار الكهربائي هناك مشاكل
اخرى اصبحت الان تواجه المواطنين شكرا
جزيلا لك يعقوب مديره المكتب العربيه في
الخرطوم
المواجهه العسكريه بين قائد القوات
المسلحه ونائبه صورتها صحيفه فاينش تايمز
اعلاميا وجها لوجه خصما قويا مصممان على
القتال حتى النهايه كل منهما لن يتراجع
حتى تحقيق اهدافه ويرمي كره التهدئه في
ملعب الاخر وفق التصريحات الطرفين للصحيفه
مواجهه البرهان واحمد العسكريه بارض
المعركه يقابلها تنافس اعلامي لا يقل حده
وفي وقت اكد احمد عدم التراجع عن اهدافه
على اعتبار ان ارض المعركه ستحدد كل شيء
لفت البرهان الى خروج جزء كبير من قوات
احمدتي عن السيطره قائد قوه الدعم السريع
اعتبر ان البرهان ليس مستعدا للانتقال
للحكم المدني لكن الاخيره اكد استئناف
الانتقال للمسار الديمقراطي بمجرد هزيمه
احمد
اهداف احمدتي تشمل اعتقال البرهان
ومحاكمته اهداف تبين محاوله الدعم السريع
الاستيلاء على السلطه وفق البرهان حمدتي
شدد على عدم معارضه دمج قواته بالجيش من
حيث المبدا الجيش اكد الالتزام باستكمال
العمليه السياسيه وفق الاتفاق الايطالي
ترشق كلامي يستكمله احمد تي بتاكيد
انفتاحه على وقف اعمال العطف لكنه يؤكد
ايضا ان البرهان لن يتوقف فيما يتهم قائد
الجيش قوه حميتي باعمال نهب في الخرطوم
ودارفور
معكم ايضا تطورات احتجاج او احتجازي جنود
المصريين هتلر الاشتباكات الدائره في
السودان حيث اكد المتحدث العسكري للجيش
المصري اتخاذ كافه اجراءات التعاون
والتنسيق مع الاجهزه الامنيه السودانيه
لتامين عوده القوات المصريه الى بلادهم
لفتاه الى هبوطي ثلاث طائرات نقل عسكريه
في احد احد مطارات السودان واخلت او اخليت
دفعه من القوات المصريه وعادت بهم الى
احدى القواعد العسكريه الجويه في القاهره
اضاف المتحدث العسكري بانه تم تامين وصول
باقي الجنود المصريين لمقر السفاره تمهيدا
لاجراءات اخلائه من السودان فورا توفر
الظروف الامنيه المناسبه
في سياق اخر نفت القوات المسلحه الليبيه
بقياده خليفه حفتر تقديم الدعم لطرف ضد
الاخر من طرفي الصراع الدائري في السودان
وضح المتحدث باسم الجيش الوطني الليبي
احمد المسماري ان القوات المسلحه الليبيه
تقوم حاليا باجراء الاتصالات العاجله مع
الاطراف المعنيه مضيفا بان القياده مستعده
للقيام بدور الوساطه بين الاشقاء في
السودان لوقف القتال
ونعود الى الخرطوم مره اخرى الى الكاتب
الصحفي محمد شمس الدين محمد هل من تطورات
في الموقف
يعني بينما نحن نتحدث في هذه اللحظات
اصوات الطيران سلاح الطيران
واصوات الاطلاقات من المدافع الرشاشه
كثيفه جدا
على ما يبدو ان الطيران يقوم بقصف اهداف
معينه بشكل متتالي
نحاول تمييز
الموقع الذي
يتم الاطلاق عليه ومنه
هذه الاصوات قادمه من الشريط اذن
شريط شارع المطار المؤدي الى الى القياده
العامه واصوات الاطلاقات اطلاقات الرد
قادمه ايضا من الارتكازات غالبا التي في
الاحياء التي هي في غرب المطار من اكثر من
موقع تتم هذه الاطلاقات يعني الصباح هذا
اليوم وقبل شروق الشمس لاحظت عمليه
اطلاقات هذه وتجدر الاشاره هنا الى انه
لم تكن هناك حركه طيران كثيفه صباح اليوم
لكن ربما يعني مره طلع او طلعتين كانت
يعني واضحه بعد ذلك كانت هذه الاطلاقات
تتم بكل اسف شديد يعني مع مرور
الطيران الدولي فوق اجواء السودان وهي
بعيده جدا طبعا هذه كميه هذه الاطلاقات
تحصل في الهواء وبدون مبرر وبالتالي فان
بعض هذه القذائف تسقط في اماكن مدنيه
اماكن ماهوله بالسكان هذا ما يؤدي الى
كثير من الاصابات ربما
يستمعون
واضح الان
في دليل او المؤشر على مواجهات واشتباكات
ايضا عنيفه الان في اكثر من منطقه في
الاحياء القريبه كما قال قبل قليل زميل
محمد شمس الدين في الاحياء المؤديه
للقاعده العامه واحياء ايضا محيط
المطار وقسم كذلك جوي متتالي يقوم بها او
تقوم بها القوات الجيش الان في هذه
المنطقه المشكله الان في هذه الاستهدافات
الجويه خصوصا محمد في مناطق كثيفه
بسكان المدنيين من خلال المباني المتواجده
فيها بالتالي لا يمكن الحديث عن دقه هذه
الاهداف او دقه هذا القصف الموجهه لهذه
الاهداف
صحيح تماما يعني خاصه وان هذه
المنطقه يعني جميع شوارعها يعني شوارع
ضيقه وهذه تمركزات لهذه القوات تكون داخل
هذه الاحياء وداخل هذه الشوارع هذه
الاشكاليه كبرى بالمناسبه ان تمت
استهدافات لهذه المركبات داخل هذه الشوارع
لكن اغلب الظن ان هذه
الاستهدافات بالطيران تكون
في المناطق المفتوحه منطقه
القياده العامه كلها
وجنوب هذه المنطقه اقصد شارع اقصد المطار
باكمله تعتبر منطقه مفتوحه وهي المنطقه
الرئيسيه التي تحصل فيها الاطلاقات من قبل
سلاح الطيران على الاهداف الخاصه
بالدعم السريع لمركبات المتحركه للدعم
السريع ومدرعاتها
فلذلك لم لم يعني
نحصل او لم تريد اي تقارير حول اصابات
مباشره بهذه
السلاح الطيران في الاحياء السكنيه وهذا
امر يعني ايجابي حتى هذه اللحظه نتمنى ان
يستمر كذلك ونتمنى ان تكون هناك طريقه
لاخراج هذه القوات الى خارج هذه المنطقه
طيب عمليه استهداف جديده الان في هذه
اللحظات نستمع اليه
[موسيقى]
انا اكتفي معك بهذا القدر بالتاكيد
الزملاء ايضا في ساعتنا القادمه سيكون
تواصل ايضا الوقوف على اخر المستجدات في
التطورات في المواجهات التي نواجه الان
اجزاء مصوره منها في التي تدل على
اشتباكات عنيفه الان من خلال ارتفاع اعمده
الدخان الان في سماء العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات